FAA is the mother of a young man who is
wanted by Israel and says she's being
harassed threatened and violently
pressured by the Israeli military to
surrender her
son I spent 9ine days in prison they
told me to give up my son or they will
come back and take me and boom my
house after I left prison they were
calling us around the clock I was so
stressed because they threatened to kill
my son they also come back ransacked the
house and threatened to arrest my
daughter her husband says he's also
being treated like a criminal and has
been imprisoned twice in two
months
hey look at this picture they bounded my
hands put a blindfold on me they threw
me onto my face into a Jeep where they
beat and kicked me I asked what did I do
they told me my son is wanted and they
want him to surrender
a Palestinian prisoner Rights group says
this is a form of collective punishment
that's illegal under international human
rights
law since October 7th this policy of
arresting family members of wanted
people is happening more frequently and
we're especially seeing the women wives
and mothers being used there are
hundreds of people now being used as
captives to put pressure on family
members to H themselves in since
Israel's war on Gaza more than 6,000
people have been arrested and placed in
administrative detention in the occupied
West Bank often in Israeli prisons
without any formal charges or trial just
5 minutes from tubas we're here in tmon
where more families are facing the same
there are among dozens across the
occupied West Bank who have been
arrested interrogated and put into
prison to give information on family
members and to enter the pressure here
they say they have to endure almost
nightly raids and drones continue
continuously circling overhead in ton
Muhammad ashat says his brother is
wanted by the Israeli Army for
questioning he shows me where the Army
broke into his house at night smashing
in the metal door Sly went a h they
asked about my brother I told him I
don't know where he is then they started
beating me they didn't find him so they
destroyed the door and entered my house
and took me instead they interrogated me
for 8 hours in an open
area he says the recent breaking is caus
one of his children to constantly shake
and like so many across the occupied
West Bank he says these arrests are
another form of Oppression that's
continued for Generations Laura Khan
aljazera occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer